[Music]
Cerberus an unofficial name what do you
know about Greek myths like me nothing
maybe I do know because I looked at
Cerberus is the guardian of the
Underwood and we think of the underworld
as hell therefore hot
[Music]
heat waves happen every year this one is
sitting over southern Europe but it's
not moving the general Trend around the
world is that each Heat Wave is slightly
worse than the last most likely a direct
result of the changing climate because
one of the consequences of that is that
the weather patterns used to move slowly
around the world so a heat wave lasted
say 10 days then it was moved on that
doesn't happen the jet stream has been
part in a certain pattern so you get
Persistence of one type of weather if
you have a heat wave it will persist
Persistence of this anticyclope that we
have unofficially called Cerberus means
that temperatures go up and up and up
and we'll break more records and I don't
see things improving anytime soon yes
summer will go to Autumn will lose this
heat wave but next year it'll come back
it'll be slightly worse maybe somewhere
different but the trend is very clear
and cannot see changing to our benefit
anytime soon
foreign
[Music]